hi i'm tom green and here's one thing  you can do to help the environment  separate your garbage okay i've been  doing this lately separate your cans  your glass your styrofoam  your plastic and your compostables so  when you're traveling in a van camping  out in the natural world you want to  leave the environment the same way it  was when you when you came there so you  don't want to leave any garbage around  of course bring biodegradable plastic  bags with you don't leave anything there  and pack in pack out or something like  that i forgot what it is anyways google  that try not to bring too many plastic  bottles you know you can bring a larger  source of water so you don't leave a lot  of plastic bottles understand that when  you're in nature  it's a natural environment leave it  undisturbed pack out all your garbage  keep it beautiful  [Music]